hey guys it's angelico with max tech and
i just upgraded to an iphone 13 pro from
my 10r that i've had for years now and
i've gotta say it's been long overdue
this phone has been the subject of my
dreams every night for the past six
months ever since vadim made his first
iphone 13 leaks video and going from
something like my 10r which is now
officially discontinued by apple to this
phone is a crazy upgrade so in this
video i'm going to talk about all the
changes i've experienced so far
switching to this 13 pro both good and
bad and then i'm gonna get into how it's
changed my day-to-day life as an average
consumer and if it's worth coughing up
the dough this year if you currently
have a much older iphone like the 10r
let's start off with the most obvious
difference and that is the square design
i love the flush display and flat
stainless steel sides of the pros they
really stand out and make the phone look
like a slab of premium if premium were a
noun to this day sometimes i stop what
i'm doing and i just sit there admiring
the new design it almost looks too nice
for me to own especially side by side
with my 10r even though on paper it
doesn't look like much in the hand i can
feel a considerable weight difference
for me this is a slight disadvantage
because it's definitely less comfortable
to lay down and watch movies for long
periods of time and i'm now deathly
afraid of dropping this phone on my face
let's move on to the feature that made
me want to upgrade in the first place
and that is promotion i absolutely love
this feature everything is so smooth and
so crisp it's so much easier on the eyes
and it looks fantastic and switching
made anything that uses 60 hertz look
terrible and it is impossible not to
notice the difference now promotion is
something interesting and that to me and
pretty much everyone into tech it is a
huge deal and a really big reason to
upgrade but for most casual consumers it
doesn't really matter joshua chang made
a video where he brought in five of his
friends and gave them 13 pros to play
with and see if they notice a difference
in refresh rate
and out of the five only one person
noticed without help from joshua and
when asked if they would upgrade for
this feature the consensus was that it's
great and looks nice but it's not
something worth paying the money for
this is better i suppose but like
not enough for me to like really
complain about it from my phone and
that's absolutely true you do not need
it it looks and it feels great and i was
very excited for it but is it really
that important for the average user
probably not unless you want to do 120
fps mobile gaming a great thing about
promotion though is that it improves
battery life because the refresh rate
adapts in real time and can go down to
10 hertz you're saving battery life
compared to it being locked at 60 hertz
and i know a lot of you may say that hey
samsung smartphones like the s21 ultra
have already had this feature so it's
not really impressive but the thing is
that the s21 ultra actually wastes
battery life it's advertised as being
able to go down to 10 hertz as well
but users have noticed that on static
images it stays at 60 hertz and it only
goes down to 48 hertz when viewing 20
fps video and some people have tested
the always on display and apparently it
also stays at 60 hertz now before i get
into my real world experience with
battery life on this 13 pro compared to
my old 10r i want to ask you guys to
subscribe because apparently only around
23 percent of you are
and with that you can help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers before the
end of the year we'd really appreciate
it back to battery life it is insane
ever since i got the 13 pro i have not
once put it in battery saving mode
during weekdays at work i keep it on a
wireless charger so it's always topped
off and one day after typical use for me
at night before i went to bed my phone
was at 82 percent the crazy thing is i
don't even have to charge it at night on
weekends i use carplay when i drive
which simultaneously charges my phone
and topping off just from driving is
enough to keep my battery alive the
entire weekend this is incredible never
having to worry about battery life when
on my 10r i almost always had to have it
on battery saving mode and still charge
at night this is one of the biggest
things that makes it worth upgrading
especially if you have a much older
phone that you've had for years since
battery health will decline over time
the next thing i was excited for was the
smaller notch now this isn't a big deal
as it's still a mammoth compared to
literally every notch out there
but it's nice to not have it cut into
videos as much it's just been something
that we've been waiting for for years
and it finally distinguishes itself
apart from previous iphone models on the
front hopefully one day with a software
update the extra space given will be
utilized like showing your actual
battery percentage i do also really like
how the layout has changed with the
speaker grille being moved to the top of
the notch instead of in the center it
definitely makes it look much neater
however according to analyst ross young
the next iphone 14 will get rid of the
notch entirely and have a hole punch
just like most current android phones
which is going to be a game changer
especially since face id will still
likely be implemented
just under the display and speaking of
the display in real world i have noticed
a massive difference for one the 13 pro
has an oled display compared to an lcd
in the 10r with a ppi of 460 compared to
326
so it's very sharp with high contrast
but what's crazy between these is the
difference in brightness this year for
the first time the 13 pro models have a
peak typical brightness of 1000 nits
compared to the previous 800 but my 10r
has a peak of 625
that difference sounds insane and it
looks insane too i'm finally able to use
my phone outside in the sun and be able
to see what i'm doing when before i
never could especially because my 10r
would constantly dim from the heat of
the sun and speaking of dimming i have
not experienced it happening even once
so far with my 10r it would constantly
overheat and sometimes the display would
even them down to 30 percent indoors and
i don't even do things that draw crazy
amounts of power like gaming i've also
noticed a massive difference in the
speakers they are so much louder and
clearer and i can finally play music
from my phone and it's loud enough for
my liking when before i'd exclusively
use my airpods because the speakers on
the 10r were just way too quiet another
huge improvement that i'm extremely
happy about
is the increase in ram the pro models of
the 12 and 13s finally come with six
gigabytes of ram compared to four
gigabytes on all the other models and
that extra 50 changes everything it was
a constant pain having my apps refresh
every time i open them even if i only
had like three or four open and now i
finally no longer have to deal with that
problem and it is such a relief nothing
is more annoying than having a youtube
video on opening another app to check
something and having youtube refresh on
you moving on something i know a lot of
people are curious about are the
cellular speeds so we ran a test outside
and the download speed went from 52
megabytes per second to 206 and the
upload went from seven megabytes per
second to 28. literally being four times
faster in both now there are a few more
improvements that i haven't had time to
fully explore but i'm really excited to
and one of those are the cameras now
both the 10 and the 10s have dual
cameras a wide and a telephoto but i had
a 10r and that only has a single wide
lens the photo quality was pretty
terrible last month i went on a trip to
olympic national park and i was so
bummed to still have my 10r the photos
weren't so bad during the day but as it
got darker on my hike the photo quality
got worse and worse here is an out of
focus shot just for reference of how
dark it was and here is a portrait photo
i tried to take that looks like
something straight out of a horror movie
portrait photos especially nighttime got
a huge improvement this year so i'm
really excited to finally be able to get
good looking photos the last feature
that i haven't been able to utilize yet
but i'm really excited for is magsafe
there are so many accessories that i'm
already planning on purchasing just like
belkin's two-in-one charger stand from
my phone and airpods pro and this sticky
wall mount from amazon that we featured
in one of our top magsafe accessories
videos i'm planning on buying a few of
these to use when doing things like
cooking or working out you can also use
this as a simple and clean wall mount in
your car so i know the price tag of 999
is pretty hefty but this iphone 13 pro
has fully lived up to my expectations
and i am beyond thrilled to own this
phone gorgeous design 120 hertz insane
battery life and 6 gigs of ram makes
this phone more than worth it and that's
not even mentioning the insane camera
differences which alone are worth it so
if you have an older iphone and you're
wondering if this is the year to upgrade
i would personally say it depends on how
excited you are about these features if
you're like me and you've been waiting
for features like 120 hertz then
absolutely go for it i know you love
this phone as much as i do as a regular
consumer and if you really want the 14
that's coming next year i'm in the same
boat which is why i signed up for the
upgrade program don't forget that you
always have the option to pick up this
13 and then sell it next year when the
14 comes out so with all of that said i
hope this video helped you if you have
an older iphone like i did click the
button above to subscribe and go ahead
and check out one of those two videos
over there this has been angelica with
max tech thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]